mi nombre es ana fernanda maiguashca así
como suena
lo que pasa es que es en quechua
tengo 43 años me gradué en 1992 hace que
integralmente pertenezco al siglo pasado
cuando había algunas de las personas que
me iban a acompañar hoy en el escenario
pensé que claramente yo iba a estar
dentro del grupo que tenía más
experiencia digámoslo así lo cual en
este caso era una noticia feliz porque
realmente para mí esa es una ocasión
extraña
yo soy miembro de la junta directiva del
banco de la república y digamos que este
es un cargo que típicamente ha sido
ocupado por señores mayores aunque tengo
que confesar que algunos más por su
apariencia que por la cédula
y donde yo me gano sistemáticamente
miradas de desconfianza respecto de la
pertinencia de una mujer joven que se ve
un poco más joven de lo que es en este
que a veces llaman un club de sabios
soy
la segunda mujer en llegar a la junta
directiva la primera fue la doctora
maría mercedes cuéllar que cuando llegó
además ya era una persona muy importante
en la vida económica nacional
no soy la persona más joven en haber
llegado a este cargo
soy el miembro más joven en ocuparlo hoy
pero de lo que sí estoy segura es que
soy la única miembro de junta que
típicamente le preguntan cosas como oye
y tú para que codirector trabajas
esa pregunta muy lejarza no solo porque
yo no sea tan famosa como alguno de mis
colegas sino porque hay algo en mí que
no encaja en la idea que estas personas
tienen de cómo se ve un miembro de la
junta directiva
una amiga mía dice que el prejuicio
ahorra tiempo y es verdad porque como
viene antes del juicio pues imagínense
si nos quedáramos ahí todo el tiempo que
nos ahorraríamos y lo que está operando
en la mente de estas personas pues es
exactamente es un prejuicio lo cual en
realidad no tiene nada de malo todos los
tenemos pero en realidad si nos impide
muchas veces aprender cosas nuevas
así que la historia que he venido a
contarles hoy la de mi vida o el aspecto
que me pareció quizás interesante es
precisamente ese
el de cómo romper con prejuicios vencer
estereotipos los míos propios en muchos
casos los de otros y hoy en día
activamente muchos que se encuentran
presentes en la sociedad que vivimos
yo nací en cali en 1974 entré a este
colegio cuando tenía cuatro años me
adelanté eso era una sorpresa
aunque ya les dije que entre pero lo
cierto es que mi ingreso no fue tan
sencillo aparentemente contaba mi mamá
pusieron alguna condición cuando yo iba
a entrar mi mamá no era muy precisa en
esta información porque ella solamente
se acuerda que se puso muy brava cuando
le dijeron que iba a haber algún
condicionamiento y pues bueno eran otras
épocas si se puso muy brava y ahí viene
la sorpresa clash of night in actitud
ahora decía mi mamá y ella ya murió así
que esta historia no la podemos
confirmar porque si era brava en vida no
voy a ser yo quien estorbe su descanso
eterno
que la razón por la cual no me dejaron o
pusieron alguna reparo en mi ingreso en
el colegio fue por mi timidez y yo les
encuentro toda la razón porque lo cierto
es que para este entonces cuando yo
tenía cuatro años
creo que los diálogos más extensos que
había sostenido habían ocurrido dentro
de mi cabeza o con mi perro
mi hermano que me llevaba cuatro años y
aparecía ahí con otro de mis perros pues
en ese momento parece que no le parecía
tan interesante hablar conmigo pegarme
sí
yo vivía en pance pero esto era 1978 es
decir que yo estaba fundamentalmente
rodeada de especies animales o vegetales
así que pues bueno y ahí mi timidez
probablemente porque es enojo entonces
mi mamá pues aparentemente a ella le
parecía bastante obvia que era
precisamente por esa timidez que yo
necesitaba entrar al colegio ella nunca
me dijo que hubiese algo raro conmigo
por hablarle al perro porque el perro no
me contestaba ese si no tenía nada de
raro
pero lo cierto es que estaba convencida
que para ese miedo mío de estar rodeada
de gente pues lo más importante que
podía hacer por mí era rodearme de gente
así que un poco tarde ya entrados los
primeros días del inicio de clases pues
también creo que no venía el colegio
desde que me gradué exactamente por ese
mismo camino en realidad lo único que
recuerdo es el zumbido del pánico en mis
oídos hasta que de pronto de la nada
apareció juliana y me cogió de la mano
ella hoy también me está acompañando
aquí porque el pánico se parece
a mí me costó trabajo esto va
acostumbrarme a hablarle a la gente y no
a los perros aunque ya le voy cogiendo
el espíritu
en retrospectiva ya en mi vida adulta
miro hacia atrás y entiendo que
probablemente todo el tiempo sentí que
había algo raro conmigo porque yo no
acababa de encajar yo no acababa de
pertenecer ese era mi propio prejuicio
porque en realidad la única persona que
le asignaba una carga negativa a esa
rareza era yo y probablemente por muchos
años me impidió explotar
muchos potenciales míos mientras fui
validando me ganando señas de aprobación
y por eso va a ser tan importante esta
charla siempre la importancia del amor
de otros
finalmente terminé el colegio me fui a
estudiar economía en la universidad de
los andes y antes de graduarme de la
carrera entré al ser miedo y práctica
empresarial en el banco de la república
arranque con temas de política monetaria
luego digo yo que de la mano de la
suerte porque fueron mil volteretas
acabé en temas de mercados financieros y
ahí encontré una vocación
y oyendo al padre alberto quizás debería
expresar lo de otra manera
encontré una forma de expresar esa
vocación y no es la única porque tengo
la sospecha de que si hubiera entrado a
trabajar a una fábrica de zapatos yo
estaría aquí contándole sobre tacones
porque al final del día esas formas de
expresar si se quiere esa una vocación
son diferentes maneras de amar la vida y
estoy convencida que uno debe buscar
varias por si alguna saca la mano
finalmente entré a trabajar al banco en
un ambiente muy masculino preparando
esta charla pensaba yo si en realidad
éramos pocas las mujeres en el equipo y
bueno pocas y éramos pero sobre todo el
punto era que el ambiente era masculino
tomábamos cerveza hablamos de fútbol
íbamos a un bar donde el baño de hombres
tenía una ventanita y entonces ellos
podían seguir charlando nos mientras
hacían lo que tenían que hacer
la dueña se llama mariella y la queremos
mucho
pero lo cierto es que con ese prejuicio
si no llegue a yo para mí había una
limpieza respecto del tema de mi género
que quizás hizo que yo fuera avanzando
sin mayores tropiezos por lo menos en
ese aspecto
mi mamá se separó cuando eso no estaba
de moda
era economista tenía un magíster
en la universidad de georgia tech
cuando tampoco se usaba que se fueron lo
que hicieran muchas mujeres así que por
lo menos a ojos míos las mujeres
profesionalmente hacíamos aquello que
nos apasionaba y estábamos en perfecta
capacidad de ser el principal proveedor
de una casa
mi mamá fumaban tomaba whisky llegaba
muy tarde y nunca la vi tender una cama
mire
dirigía las cosas en la cocina porque la
comida en mi casa es importantísima pero
las manos que al final del día
preparaban esa comida eran las mujeres
que me cuidaban bisa que cocinaba yo
está al lado de acá izquierdo
y martic a mi niñera y él me cuido desde
que nací y aquí en la vida me regaló el
privilegio de cuidar cuando llegaron sus
años de enfermedad hasta el momento de
su muerte así que en realidad yo aprendí
todo de manos femeninas bueno casi todo
para desprestigiar a mi papá
de los negocios de las finanzas de la
cocina de las matas de las juntas
directivas de cómo hacer un florero así
que si hay algo para mi las mujeres
éramos todo poderosas porque todos los
problemas de mi casa típicamente los
resolví a una mujer y así fue entonces
en ese ambiente masculino
desenvolviendo me cada logro abría la
puerta del siguiente porque finalmente
me iba sintiendo capaz todos ellos de la
mano de mucho trabajo de muchísima
suerte que la gente a veces omite
mencionarla pero sobre todo del afecto y
la fe de mis equipos y de mis jefes
porque no fueron pocas las veces que mis
mentores fueron capaces de ver en mí
cosas que yo no estaba listas para ver
lo que sí tuve fue la sabiduría de
creerles lo que ellos veían y de tomar
todas las oportunidades que me brindaron
así que ya en el banco decidí seguir
llevando un poco la contraria y en un
territorio donde todo el mundo iba a ser
un doctorado en economía yo decidí que
iba a ser un envié
me miraron muy raro eso es cierto pero
también es cierto que me becaron así que
ve acá en mano me casé muchas decisiones
al tiempo y me fui a nueva york a la
universidad de columbia donde al que
miraron raro fue a mi marido
la organización de estudiantes
internacionales organizó un almuerzo
para los compañeros de los estudiantes
que llegábamos de otros lugares
y el pobre gustavo encontró que él era
el único hombre ocupando ese rol en ese
grupo así que ahí vamos rompiendo
paradigmas yo aprendiendo de gerencia y
de finanzas y el aprende bueno en
realidad nunca aprendió a planchar
pero yo no lo culpo porque eso es muy
difícil
a mi regreso volvía al banco estuve un
tiempo ahí
tuve un paso fugaz por el sector privado
y aproximadamente 14 meses y medio
embarazo o así se sentían el
superintendente financiero del momento
me ofreció ser su delegada adjunta que
en español quiere decir como una de las
segundas personas en la organización en
la superintendencia financiera de
colombia no era catorce y medio pero sí
eran seis y medio
en un gobierno en una entidad como esa
superintendencia tres meses de licencia
de maternidad es una eternidad y eso
salió un verso
así que no se sabía en realidad quien
estaba más loco si mi jefe o yo pero ese
fue otro voto de confianza que fue un
tremendo empujón en la dirección de
hacer las cosas que yo amaba en la
superintendencia financiera tuve un
aprendizaje profundo profesional de mis
equipos tienen una vasta experiencia
supervisión yo creo que hasta entonces
no había visto mi primer balance
financiero y personal durante esos años
enfrente el cáncer de mi niñera
teníamos que enfrentar la crisis de las
llamadas pirámides no sé si las
recuerdan todas las siglas dmg df en fin
estamos afrontando la crisis financiera
mundial al que el sistema financiero no
le pasa nada gracias a nosotros
pero sobre todo aprendí que un bebé de 5
meses es absolutamente imposible que se
quede dormido en el momento en que uno
lo deja la cuna y logra pasar por el
quicio de la puerta
pero aún así llegué vivo al final del
gobierno y el ministro entrante entonces
me llamó y me dijo que si yo quería ser
su directora de regulación financiera y
yo sin reparar ni contarle mucho que
este cargo había sido ocupado durante
los últimos 20 años solo por abogados le
dije que sí y así fue como llegué al
ministerio de hacienda el ministerio de
hacienda como siento como ese romance
tormentoso que espero todos hayan tenido
no te deja dormir te hace sufrir te hace
llorar pero tú no puedes del
enamoramiento esa es una escuela que
siempre llevaré en mi corazón
en la que fui realmente muy feliz pero
nunca en la vida ha trabajado tanto
durante dos años ocupe este cargo y ya
en ese momento se empezaba a sentir el
desgaste físico y para hacerles franco
un poco el económico así que estaba
buscando yo mi estrategia de salida
cuando el ministro me llamó y me dijo
que si yo quería hacer su viceministra
técnica
era menos sueldo porque así pasan los
ministerios muchísimo más trabajo así
que como decirle que no
fui viceministra por un año largo lo que
pasa es que eso en el ministerio de
hacienda- pasa como por debajo del agua
tuve unas experiencias increíbles
durante ese año méxico nos invitó a ser
parte de las reuniones del g-20 nosotros
nos llegamos y no hace 24 así que
aprendí un montón de diplomacia
económica internacional también tuve a
bien caerme en mis rodillas en frente de
varios dignatarios del resto del mundo
preparamos durante muchísimos meses una
reforma tributaria estructural que iba a
presentar el ministro echeverry
solamente que él decidió retirarse antes
de que lo hiciéramos y con el nuevo
ministro el ministro cárdenas decidimos
presentar otra que aparentemente era
menos ambiciosa
aquí voy a entrar en algo de tecnicismos
recortamos muchos de los aportes
parafiscales que se hacen en colombia y
hoy en día según algunos estudios
técnicos se demuestra que fuimos capaces
de generar las condiciones para la
creación de más de 600 mil empleos
formales
este mes
ya
y va a decir que quizás a ustedes eso no
les sonaba tan sexy pero en realidad si
lo es no dormí durante tres meses mi
hija que a duras penas hablaba ya
empezaba a hablar de ponencia para
primer debate y segundo debate mis
equipos acampaban en mi sala a mí me dio
una grupo horrible y tuve que mostrarle
la cola a un señor congresista que dijo
que me iba a aplicar una inyección de
penicilina ni me dolió ni me curó así
que yo creo que no era penicilina
pero lo cierto es que nunca he tenido un
equipo más maravilloso que liderar ni un
líder más comprometido que esté que se
los presentó el responsable de esas
tareas que a veces no se ven tan
importantes pero que en el fondo están y
subyacen a esta nuestra vocación
con esa credencial en la mano me parecía
que quizás yo tenía el suficiente
armamento para presentarme como
candidata a la junta directiva del banco
de la república cargo que elige el
presidente
así que me convencí de todo lo que yo
había expandido con esta experiencia y
creo que por primera vez en mi vida fui
yo quien levante la mano para mostrar
las cosas que yo podía traer esta carga
y finalmente el 21 de febrero del 2013
el presidente me llamo anunciarme que
era yo quien iba a ocupar este cargo
eso fue un jueves el 23 de febrero
sábado me se parece
porque el libretista de mi vida parece
retirado de una comedia gringa y así fue
como llegué al banco de la república
cuando llegue al banco me sorprendieron
muchísimo el número de entrevistas que
me hicieron yo soy un economista una
cantante
pero sobre todo el número de veces que
me preguntaron qué se sentía ser la
segunda mujer que llegaba a la junta
directiva del banco de la república
yo les soy franca yo solo está
absolutamente emocionada porque era la
primera vez que yo llegaba
pero lo cierto es que tuve tiempo de
hacer un alto en el camino y mirar con
pausa hacia atrás y reconocer con la
perspectiva que dan las batallas
perdidas y ganadas algunas pocas
que quizás el recorrido mío no había
sido el mismo en mis colegas y no me
refiero ya a los méritos profesionales
que ellos en muchos casos tienen muchos
más sino por algo que estaba íntimamente
relacionado con mi género porque verán
yo nunca he oído que en una entrevista a
ninguno de los que ustedes vieron en la
primera foto le hayan preguntado oye y
tú cómo combinas la paternidad con la
política monetaria
y sin embargo ellos los que son papás al
menos se merecen que les hubieran hecho
esta pregunta a mí por lo menos me ha
encantado contestarla
de manera que ha tenido tiempo para
pensar en prejuicios en estereotipos en
ideas preconcebidas que tenemos
viendo justamente otro texto en adelante
entregó todos los derechos de autor de
la doctora lisa feldman una
neurocientífica de psicóloga
me encontré este experimento que es el
que ella presenta en esa charla y que yo
tomé para poder ilustrar mi punto
ella presenta esta gráfica en este
momento ustedes todos tienen que
sentirse muy confundidos y ver unas
manchas blancas y negras y no saber qué
es eso y aparentemente ese fenómeno
tiene un nombre o ellos lo bautizaron
como ceguera empírica o así traduje yo
la expresión en inglés que era
experience of wine
y luego ella los cura de la ceguera y
entonces pasa esto
y entonces la siguiente vez ustedes en
la cual habrá cierto que si se pone el
caso de ella ha funcionado perfecto
lo que para mí por todo este experimento
en realidad fue el enorme riesgo que
encontré de que esa incomodidad que nos
genera de no reconocer una experiencia
nueva o algo que no conocemos que no
hemos explorado que eso nos impida o
ponga en riesgo nuestra capacidad de
innovar nuestra capacidad de crear y en
última instancia nuestra capacidad de
ser felices si es que para hacerlo
necesitamos hacer alguna transformación
así que esa es la historia que en
realidad viene a contarles hoy
porque esa carrera mía ha sido la de
vencer prejuicios la de no encajar nunca
en el molde ni siquiera en el que yo
había pensado debía ocupar y la deben
ser mis miedos porque de lo contrario
mis ideas más locas y créanme que fueron
varias
no sería no hay parte de mis orgullos
sino en mis fantasmas
yo fui niña en tierra de niños una
envidia en tierra de doctorados de
ascendencia indígena con apellido
quechua pidan pizza y verán
economista donde había abogados
financiera donde había macro economistas
viceministra en horas de ser mamá mamá
en horas de oficina yo no le pegue a
nada
pero acerté en todo
así que hoy viene a invitarlos para que
ustedes también se dejen amparar por ese
amor de otros permitan que sus
intuiciones guíen sus entusiasmos que no
permitan que sus miedos ni los de los
demás
maten sus sueños ni esa capacidad de
transformar
como todas las personas que ustedes han
visto y estoy segura que quien sigue al
habla también lo mostrará porque esa es
la vocación
així del ser humano la de venir a la
tierra para evolucionar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]